after a week in which the country was
attacked by more than a hundred Russian
missiles Rishi sunak made his first
visit to meet president zielinski really
good to see you it's very good for you
well there we go I've got my coat for
later he described the meeting as
humbling and pledged 50 million to
bolster the country's air defenses the
courage of the Ukrainian people is an
inspiration to the world
in years to come we will tell our
grandchildren of your story how a proud
and Sovereign people stood up in the
face of an appalling onslaught
how you fought
how you sacrificed
how you prevailed
with the first snow of winter arriving
the arms pledge is aimed at helping
Ukraine defend against attacks on
critical infrastructure
facing humiliations on the battlefield
the kremlin's resorted to hitting energy
and Water Supplies with the aim of
weakening the resolve of the civilian
population
many parts of the country have no
running water and are facing power
shortages as the temperatures drop
the meeting is also significant as it
comes after a chaotic period in British
politics and it was a chance for the
prime minister to reassure a key Ally
that the UK's support would be
unwavering as prime minister of the
United Kingdom I'm proud of how we stood
with you from the very beginning and I'm
here today to say that the United
Kingdom will continue to stand with you
this year alone we have provided 2.3
billion pounds of Military Support
and we will do the same again next year
[Applause]
includes 125 anti-aircraft guns
equipment to defend against Iranian
drones which have caused widespread
devastation
UK forces will also increase their
training of Ukrainian troops as more
soldiers are sent to the front the war
here shows no sign of ending anytime
soon neither does British support an
involvement in this conflict Alex Rossi
Sky news Ukraine